seaman eric says apologies for the weird
question have you ever performed a
ritual sacrifice no I haven't and it is
a weird question although I can
understand what you would ask it I have
performed psychological sacrifices you
know I suppose when I decided to give up
something that I needed to give up so
that I could move forward into the
future that certainly happened when I
quit smoking and when I more or less
quit drinking I still have a drink from
time to time now but I quit for 20 years
and that was a sacrifice I couldn't
continue to drink again I said I was
from northern Alberta it was pretty hard
drinking culture I really liked alcohol
but I couldn't drink and write and do my
PhD and manage my family
responsibilities it was too much and so
I stopped and that was a good thing so
that was a sacrifice